perhaps it might be a good idea those of
you who really don't know an awful lot
about this to just step back a bit and
say well how did typesetting and
printing come about anyway and I'm sure
many of you out there know that it goes
back hundreds if not thousands of years
in the Far East particularly it was
possible to make marks on paper for
Chinese Japanese Arabic characters
hundreds and hundreds of years ago those
of you know as in Western Europe often
fall into the trap of thinking well
really printing was invented in 1456 I
think it was by Johann Gutenberg in
Mainz in Germany and of course he
produced the famous Gutenberg Bibles but
I think in all fairness you've got to
say he didn't invent it he rediscovered
it perhaps he refined the techniques and
so on
so to give you some idea I've got here a
sample of wooden type and if you look
down here it's actually for a font
called castle on which some of you may
even have the modern form of under
windows on your Macintosh or whatever
that's just a display case but it it
shows in many ways the way used to have
to set your type you had to have a
wooden frame as big as the page size
that you wanted if you had type of this
huge size fine
you could even handle it with your
fingers and put it in in exactly the
layout and format you wanted most of the
time you didn't have the luxury of
anything that big that is metal type
it's metal type for a font called uni
there it's effectively a if you like a
sort of French equivalent of the Swiss
Helvetica type its sans-serif very clean
very nice but just look at the size of
it this is 10-point uni there can you
imagine that if you wanted to set one of
your papers or your letters with
individual pieces of metal type you
would be down to having a wooden frame
and with your nimble fingers
and tweezers maybe if you're going to
set a 10-point you'll be picking these
up putting them in lines having to
accept the fact if you think about it
you're going to put paper on top of
these and link make an impression
therefore these have to be mirror images
in order to look right when you take the
paper off and typically if you're on a a
four size page you're looking at
something 25 times the area of this all
to be done by hand and all to be made
absolutely perfect no typos no nothing
and how do you space the lines well up
at the top of this box there's some flat
looking pieces in there and those are
pieces of what nowadays will be called
leading if they're making lead type
which I don't know if this is but anyway
the leading is the line spacers that go
between your lines of type so you have
to insert all those you have to make the
lines look even the next stage is to
gently rolling all over it not too much
ink you don't want blocks to appear on
your paper and you would then put it in
a press very much like an apple press or
a cider press it's got a great big plate
on it one of screw threads with a big
handle at the top and the idea is
uniformly and under high pressure to
press the paper evenly onto the ink type
and then take the pressure off pull off
the paper and if you're skilled enough
you've got a beautifully eight version
of what's there in your type from
Gutenberg's time for the next 400 years
nothing fundamentally changed what
changed in all of this in the late 19th
century was that the setting of metal
type instead of having to be done by
hand became mechanised methods were
devised for using these type samples
almost as masters and being able to
replicate copies of them in a thing
called a type caster and once you got
lots and lots and lots and lots of type
enough to do a whole version of The
Washington Post or the New York Times or
whatever then what you needed was some
way of mekin
the placement of this replica type that
machine was invented in Germany in about
1880 I think or there abouts by a
gentleman called Morgentaler he founded
a very famous company called
Mergenthaler the parent company but the
name of the machine that did all this
was the liner type and as its name
implies it set lines of type which is
exactly what the newspaper industry
wanted a little bit later arrival came
along worked under different principles
which tended to corner over the years
rather more thee if you like quality end
of the book market rather than
newspapers of that bashed off every
single day of the week that was known as
the mana time machine I'm not saying the
one to others what plenty of others
because type was a good way to make a
good living as long as you had the
craftsmanship and the skills and so on
but the big two were certainly monotype
and Linotype like the General Motors and
Ford there were others but those are the
big big names well yeah Apple and
Microsoft maybe so that technology
persisted for about another 50 60 70
years of just setting metal type and
putting in a printing press
pressing the paper down and and so on
but the next big revolution that came
along from about the middle nineteen
forties onwards was the idea of having
your type not as metal but as if you
like photographic images of the
characters so if you can imagine it
inside a big light type box you would
have a on a circular drum a strip of
film that's got the whole shall we say
of Times Roman up right at the top and
then below it times italic all the
characters times bold times bold italic
not all worked on exactly this principle
but it gives you the idea and certainly
the one they got at Bell Labs
this sort of second-generation
typesetter was very much like this so
I'll stick to this description you've
got all of your characters in the
current font available as photographic
images what you've now got to do is to
transfer the photographic image of the
capital letter S shall we say from the
strip onto a piece of photosensitive
paper at the back of the box and
remember this is all light tight so what
you have is an unbelievably complex
system of mirrors and lenses capable of
either shrinking or expanding the master
letter S to be the 36 point or 6 point
or whatever you're wanting so the sizing
was done optically by magnifying and
diminishing and when you are happy that
you've got the letter S to the right
size this all takes place in
milliseconds I might say with great
noise in the background then you say
right I'm ready to print my letter S so
you would fire a strobe a strobe light
would take the image of the letter S
focus it down through a fiber optic
bundle and the fiber optic bundle would
be positioned just above the
photographic paper at the back at
exactly the place where the letter S
needed to be imaged and then you'd move
the bundle a little bit off to the right
and then maybe you do a little case
letter a next door to it so you can
probably imagine it was mechanized but
it wasn't ultra-fast you've got a lot of
things to move a lot of synchronization
to do in firing lights and so on but
nevertheless it worked
and monotype and Linotype had machines
working on this principle but they
weren't the only ones and the
interesting thing is that at Bell Labs
in the early 1970s they actually had one
of these true photo typesetters it was
made by a small firm called graphic
Systems Inc of Massachusetts
so forgot to ask Brian exactly how much
it cost but I would reckon tens of
thousands of dollars armed with that and
the computer science section
labs developed an extended text
formatting system called tear off which
was capable of typesetting to this
machine I should say that the GSI was
just about computer drivable as it was
supplied to you the idea was to drive it
completely off paper tape which you
prepared offline however it was possible
to buy some extra electronics it was not
a dedicated mini computer even in those
days far too early with specialist
electronics you could buy which would
enable you to interface a parallel port
type interface offer pdp-11 shall we say
and to drive it directly from the pdp-11
and that's exactly what Bell Labs did so
there they were with a text for matter
which had been developed in the late
sixties early seventies there were lots
of them around there's one MIT I think
will run off Johanna at Bell Labs
developed one called
rough and what happened in those early
days was if you're an ordinary Roth
normal rough as it were just to 8x4
matter
that wasn't a typesetter again it's back
at this sort of quality that was called
n Roth okay but if in the future you
wanted much better quality material you
would have something developed called
tear off and tear off standing for
typesetter version of ralph was capable
of producing properly types at outport
looking just like this that's the way it
was
at Bell Labs from about 1972 to about
1979 there was tear off and it's to
pre-processors a guy there called Mike
Lesk developed one called double for
typesetting tables he wrote in a tabular
language how we wanted your tables
laying out and doubles job was to
translate your high-level spec into
low-level tier of code
and to squirt it into tea ruff Brian and
his collaborator at the time Lorinda
cherry wrote another one which was
really just made your jaw drop open to
actually typeset mathematics and it's
hard for me to believe actually even now
that with the aid of EQ n as of 1972
vintage you could very easily typeset a
page of that sort of complexity this is
actually from a little bit later on it's
university of nottingham examination
cover sheet but that's the sort of
mathematics typesetting you could do
with using eqn to drive this two-year
off program by the end of seven or eight
years of very very heavy usage the poor
old GSI cat was on his knees and Brian
and his gang decided that they just had
to have a replacement and by that stage
the third generation had come along the
third generation of typesetters actually
used mini computers and actually
represented the fonts as data inside a
computer file
the only problem then is well it's all
very wonderful but how do you actually
get an image how do you make an image
how you know what do you do well in the
third generation typically you used a
very high precision cathode ray tube to
image your characters of course as you
all know cathode ray tubes were the
technology for televisions for many many
years and yes you could make a cathode
ray tube you still can to be very high
precision indeed and by high precision
I'm talking about shall we say 972 dots
to the inch now if you're going to make
it that high precision you are certainly
not going to have a widescreen TV at
that sort of resolution not in those
days anyway this was where the actual
imaging took place and here there is a
cartridge holding the silver bromide
positive paper or your photographic
negative film and
underneath this black cover is the
high-resolution cathode ray tube some
where yes is a picture of the high-res
cathode region which is like a letterbox
and essentially blue yeah
and essentially what happened was you
exposed the bromide paper in bands and
when you finish doing the current band
you mechanically move the bromide away
from it if you wanted to do superscript
and subscript work just by as it were
dodging and weaving within the letterbox
that could be done without moving the
bromide and that was very much favored
mechanical alignment problems were a big
big issue you had to have very high
quality gears with no backlash because
if you're sitting a two column newspaper
and if you decide to do it by doing the
left-hand column first and then winding
back the bromide to the top and doing
the right-hand column next you didn't
have come across alignment problems that
the two sides didn't really match up and
so it was very much favoured exposing it
in a band if you're doing two column
work to arrange in your software to hop
the gutter as it were as it was called
do it all in one go do a bit of
left-hand column and a piece of
right-hand column at the same time
you